there was a recently a house
intelligence subcommittee hearing on
ufos that you were a part of what was
the goal of that hearing and can you
maybe summarize what
you heard the hearings from my
perspective uh seemed a bit disingenuous
uh kind of top level uh i think um who
was the run by deciding to interrupt
like who were the people involved and
what was the goal the stated goal
congressman andre carson
did chair of the committee and he he was
i think ultimately responsible for
bringing it all together
you know i think the intent from
congress was to try to bring light to
what has been happening with the navy
and to help
show the american people that um
congress is taking this serious because
something serious is happening
but you know the sense i got seemed a
bit disingenuous they talked around it a
lot they you know advertised their
um their love of science fiction um but
they you know they didn't treat this i
would say in the manner it deserved as a
potential tactical threat if it's coming
from a foreign power
um and i get it though at the same day
they have very specific objectives
within the dod right they have a very
important job their job isn't
necessarily to do exploratory science
for no reason
so i i applaud and i encourage their
efforts on the intelligence side to help
understand this
but my concern is that they
play a role they're not well suited for
which is is doing science
you